the New York Stock Exchange where
traders had their temperatures checked
coronavirus fears led to another
terrible day for stocks Monday amid
growing fears the world may be headed
into a new global recession consumer
spending makes up 68 percent of the US
economy and investors are worried the
pandemic will force Americans to tighten
their belts CBS News business analyst
Jill Schlesinger joins us again with
some tips on how to cope with all this
financial uncertainty Jill good morning
and we've heard business owners this
morning say Eric repair the chef I just
can't keep my employees you know during
this when I have to shut my restaurants
down you know business owners saying
we're just we're not trying to make any
money we're just trying to stay in
business so a lot of people are sitting
home worried about whether they're gonna
have a job how do you prioritize what
you're gonna do with your money at this
point I think we're in conservation mode
and this is a really important concept
because even if you're lucky enough to
have some money already set aside for an
emergency what you need to do is go back
to basics and let's look at your monthly
bills that you have right you're gonna
prioritize the most important bills for
you to pay our food and shelter no
matter what we used to throw utilities
in there but I want to be clear that
many states and many municipalities are
right now banning utility shutdowns
so that's not your number-one bill again
food and shelter then list everything
else and if you can make some partial
payments that's great but food and
shelter
those are your priority let's talk about
the everything else because we've got
record credit card debt in this country
got car loans in this country mortgages
student debt I mean which of those do
you prioritize or do you pay them at all
at this point well I think that again
once we're done with food and shelter
then some utilities maybe insurance
maybe you've got some medical and
pharmaceutical needs then we are talking
about some of the debt now here's some
interesting news the FDIC sent a note
out to all of the major banking
institutions suggesting not mandating
but suggesting that they do something
that's called forbearance which means
back off guys
people are struggling and that backing
off period can mean waiving fees making
sure there's no late payments extending
the deadlines and what I think is
important right now is to make sure that
in those debts that you know again that
comes after the priorities a little bit
can go a long way
don't forget the president also said
that all interest on federal student
loans so that's a one point six trillion
dollars in outstanding loans all
interest is suspended I think there's
gonna be a lot of clean up after but I
wouldn't be rushing to pay down those
deaths anytime soon yeah you answered a
lot of questions I was thinking many
Americans are now working from home is
there anything that the internet
providers can do to help on that end I
love this piece of it because this is a
new normal right and now we're hearing
that many internet service providers are
doing a lot of things they're providing
access to low-income workers they are
making sure that they ramp up their
speeds they are also doing something
that I think is important which is
suspending data caps waiving those late
fees that often will occur people cannot
afford to have their internet service
shut down or delayed or slowed down this
is incredibly important it's a great
part of the story because the providers
did this on their own they didn't need a
lot of cajoling yeah if the only thing
you can do to get in touch with friends
and family called grandma is FaceTime
you don't want the data to get in the
way so that's a great one there Jill
thank you very much
sure